hey guys welcome back to a brand new
video and hey it's been a little bit's
like I haven't seen you guys in a couple
months right right yeah by the way
welcome back to a brand new video guys
we're back on a foreigner again and
today's gonna be going over the April
roadmap I had a feeling it would come
out today just didn't make any sense
that they would release it like next
week so today's gonna be a pretty short
video just going over what we're gonna
be talking about and you know what to
expect in April and then maybe some
theories talking about what's happening
in May so as always like to be doing
judge subscribe every new let's get
started with today's video so yeah like
I said we're gonna be talking about the
road map so let's not waste any time
well let's get straight into it today's
April 9th we have the extra XP fest
going from April 9th all the way to
April 23rd so a two week egg double xp
event just for the whole two weeks it's
gonna be [ __ ] insane and it's not
I've saw a couple people commenting on
the video this doesn't mean that it's
going to be two weekends in a row it's
two whole weeks
like in it like 14 days it's a lot of
double xp this to these next couple
weeks so definitely get on as soon as
you can grind out those new heroes
increase that rep score do as much as
you can in that two weeks on top of that
we also have the sound Mesa celebration
and the new content of the week which we
talked about in the past video
April 10th that we have is a warrior
challenge on the 12th we're gonna have
the year for season one factual more
results if you've already checked the
facts from where you know that the
Vikings have already won since they've
won three season so no surprise there
but on the 12th I will be covering what
those specific rewards are for the
Viking brethren so if we keep an eye on
that video on the 16th we have realistic
duel with special Vanquisher challenge
and the samurai of hoorah gay arcade
quest realistic golf course classic game
mode it's just gonna be duel with of
course no HUD on so have fun trying to
smack your opponent with no guard stance
all that general stuff you have to go
based off the animation on the 23rd we
have tales of metal Arcade Quest and
then more content of the week with the
24th being in our ranks Slayer
challenged in the 30th just being in
arcade quest now
I'm predicting the 23rd is executions
you know possibly a hot take but if
we're going through past trends of other
seasons in May at the new season was
supposed to release you know first week
or so of May
and usually what happens is that the
executions come out a couple weeks
before the new seasons that we can play
them before the new seasons out and wait
to experience all the really cool
executions that the devs have made for
us every season and usually like I said
they're two weeks or three weeks
beforehand and this seems to be perfect
there's no contact coming out on the
30th and the only newest content we're
getting is on the 23rd in terms of
content of the week so that's what I'm
predicting now the only issue and where
this becomes a problem is what we talked
about in the past video where the new
season is being delayed until June 11th
if you haven't seen that video
definitely check that out it's very very
important to be what we're gonna be
talking about right now but yeah so what
I said is that they are delaying the new
season until June which means all of May
is gonna have either old content like
old events or other things that we've
already gone through or maybe some small
original things that they're gonna be
releasing but I still think that the
executions are going to be releasing in
April as that was the plant it seems
like everything in April that was
supposed to release is going to release
with the only thing changing is that May
is just gonna be needing more content
because May was supposed to be the new
season so everything got basically
pushed back a month but that one section
in May that is it getting a change of
course because that was supposed to be
the new season has to get stuff added
into it so I'm predicting like I said
anything that's happening in April is
going to stay in April so it seems like
we might be getting the executions like
a month or so earlier before the new
before the new season comes out which
honestly I don't really mind I think
that's totally cool
that's just my prediction if that
doesn't come out on the 23rd then expect
me to dissect the next road map and mate
to figure out what the hell's going on
because if it doesn't come on the 23rd
it's not gonna come on in May and it
probably will be towards the end of a so
just think of that for now yeah but that
guys it's gonna be the end of the baits
here hopefully you guys did enjoy it
like I said I just wanted to make this
other video because I knew the road map
was coming out at one point I was just
waiting for it eventually to release
what that like to be if you do enjoy
subscribe for a new I cover the
informational side of foreigner that
being the balance changes to hear
updates patch notes all that kind of
stuff if you want to catch the day with
everything happening to the world of
foreigner and never miss out enough but
don't be subscribe to the channel
take care guys have grace today
peace out and I'll see you all for next
week's video
[Music]
you